so three years ago a man called Denny
Lacoste was driving near New Orleans
when he came across a tiny nutria on the
side of the road
the rodent siblings had just been hit by
a car unfortunately so Denny Lacoste
jumped into action scooped up the little
guy and rescued him he gave the animal
the name nudy and raised him as a pet
nudie is a local celebrity not
surprisingly he's also a regular at
Denny Lacoste seafood restaurant Dennis
Seafood in Metairie Louisiana so
recently the state of Louisiana because
they've solved all other problems tried
to seize nudie the pet nutria on public
health grounds but Daniel coste and his
Brave wife Myra stood up to the
government and now they've gotten word
yes the man will let them keep the
rodent Dennis and Mario lacrosse join us
now along with Duty Mr Mrs Acosta I
appreciate your coming on tonight I'm
glad to meet nudie and I just want to
thank you on behalf of all animal lovers
for your bravery in the face of State
interference
um why was it so important for you to
keep this pet
he was just a little hurt animal we felt
sorry for yeah he was so cute he felt
fit in the palm of my hand and he was
very fluffy
well he looks like he still is so so
nutrient I'm I'm embarrassed I'm not
even sure I'm pronouncing correctly is
it nutria or nutria
nutria
nutrients you're saying it right we'll
take a middle ground they're rodents but
when you get close to them they're
incredibly cute why is the State against
them
they cause they Cause a lot of damage to
the wetlands
yeah
they destroy our local canals too
yeah well I did know that but but he's
in your living room so it doesn't seem
like he's a threat to your waterways in
Louisiana what do you feed him oh no
he's
sweet potatoes corn on the cob
Popeye's Chicken
pancakes
a lot of fruits I've got a similar diet
actually I'm not even a rodent what how
does he eat fried chicken
right now he's eating a crawfish claw a
boiled crawfish cloth he loves boiled
crawfish
if he walked down
I mean so he was literally adopted by
people who have a famous restaurant so
that's pretty good if you're a stranded
orphaned rodent that's a pretty good
stroke of walk
yeah right right
yes he is a lucky one he hasn't made
are there I just I want to ask you to be
honest for one second are there any
downsides to adopting an enormous rodent
yeah he's a lot of work
he's a lot of work he kind of listens
like a cat not too good
too good can you be more specific
because I I have the feeling a lot of
our viewers are going to run out and try
to adopt a nutria what would you cost no
don't don't go get a nutria no
they can destroy your inside of your
house really quickly besides eating
pancakes and stuff like that he loves
wires
wires sofa wires
yeah any kind of wires phone charges you
got to pick all that up I don't know why
he loves wise
wow well you are giving away you were
giving me other than that
does he sleep at all woodwork
oh he sleeps all night oh yeah yeah
he'll take a towel and go into the Hall
bathroom and make a nest and he'll walk
around the house and grab all the dog
toys and shoes hats whatever is on the
floor and he'll go into the Hall
bathroom and once he goes into the
bathroom he's done for the night
oh yeah he's not nocturnal he he got
trained when I was a schedule yeah good
that's the spirit you got to make the
rodents obey I agree with that Dennis
Ryan Lacoste thank you so much nudie
great to meet you appreciate your coming
thank you thank you same here thank you
Tucker subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight